[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
the grandest of juries
find out that Bonnie Willis Georgia
paneling selecting jury members for a
grand jury investigating Trump election
fraud
oh boy this is Mike Lindell is going
absolutely [__] broke
the uh The Whistleblower I don't know if
you heard the whisp
well whistleblower is a Chinese spy
ah Jim Comer Jim Jordan the jimmies of
the Jimmy's over there
the real America First Nazi party are
really doing us a service aren't they
man really doing us a service
and you're wondering you're wondering
like why why didn't Joe Biden get out
there and refute this
because it was a [__] lie
look
at this point
we're gonna have to work hard at this
election we are but at this point
we just need to give the Republicans
and the gqp the America First Nazi party
just enough rope to hang themselves
this is [__] ridiculous are you
kidding me not only not only is The
Whistleblower
um allegations absolute 100 total
[__] and you know that just because
it's coming out of the mouths of
Republicans
period
but not only that
this guy gets indicted by the doj
for being a Chinese spy
and and also an illegal arms dealer are
you [__] [__] me
and of course the conspiracy theories
start to spring up immediately oh the
deal Jason died him to cover up Biden's
crimes
oh man
you just I mean they're never gonna stop
this stupidity
they're not gonna stop the stupidity
they're not going to admit that they're
the ones
who who who are backing criminals
that are in full support of criminals I
mean the party of projection here is not
going to admit that
but we must not take the shovel out of
their hands while they're digging their
political Graves
now back to the lead story this grand
jury we know that uh fonnie Willis plans
on bringing some sort of indictments uh
end of July beginning of August so we're
getting close
we're getting close to finding out
exactly how many people in Georgia
flipped on Donald Trump because that's
that's the actual that's the story
that's the story here I believe ever
everyone listen
again I know this is going to be
disappointing to you but I'm just
telling you the [__] truth Donald
Trump will not go on trial until after
the election stop acting like he's going
to stop it
stop if you're listening to political or
excuse me legal pundits out there these
legal experts they're [__] lying to
you stop listening to them stop if if
there is any legal person out there and
I I know there's people that are
associated with this show that are have
legal analysis if they're telling you
he's going to go on trial before the
election stop listening to them I know I
shouldn't probably say that stop
stop it's sensationalism they're
sensationalizing the [__] fact and
the timeline
okay this is just this is just how it
works
it's how it works Bonnie Willis even
when she brings the charges probably
isn't going to get most of these people
in trial think about it
think about it by time she and indicts
and arrange them it's gonna be September
October of this year
and you think we're gonna get to a trial
next next year right before the election
use your [__] thinking machine
so if you're disappointed that there's
not going to be a trial it's only
because you convince yourself of
something that doesn't exist
I've been telling you for months he's
not gonna go on trial before the
election
late last night Donald Trump's legal
team filed a motion with Canon she's
going to give it to him
it's gonna happen
I talked to someone personally when he
was first indicted in South Florida
they're like no no there was legal
analysts on TV that said that said it's
a speedy thing I'm like look I get it I
get what you're saying
but it's [__]
so if you're excited about Donald Trump
getting indicted get excited but if
you're excited about him going on trial
before the election and somehow him
going to prison save the country stop it
stop that's not what is going to happen
they're not going to save us only we can
save us oh it's us
we are Trump's jury we are the
Republicans jury
get it through your thick skulls he is
not going on trial until after the
election now
man I'm gonna tell you I'm listening to
Chris Christie talk this morning
really get inside the head of Donald
Trump
I I wish I wish to some degree that
there was space for Chris Christie to
actually get elected in the Republican
Party there's not
the [__] he's saying he'll never get
elected to another office ever in the
history of ever
Chris Christie is done in politics other
than
knocking [__] over
he's done he's not going to be able to
be elected with the [__] he's saying
he's just not because even when the
Cheeto dust q and honor is dead and gone
long gone off this Earth thing [__]
goodness
and we can rid ourselves of that [__]
fat flea bag from Mar-A-Lago listen they
are still Gonna Worship Him
I I tried to show you every [__] day
at least one instance
of how I'm painting
my
[__] forethought of why they're going
to [__] nominate him it's because
it's a cult
start there start there when you're
using your analysis
I listen to people on MSNBC and CNN Fox
News
give these legal analysis give these
election uh uh analysis commentary
punditry on on the primary the [__] out
of here these people are dumber than
dirt dumber than dog [__] and the reason
why is they don't start with the cult
they're not aware of how [__] people
get elected in this country it is
obvious and it and it's so it's so
amazing that the mainstream media has
failed themselves
they claim to know all and be so smart
and have all the data and all the facts
and they start in the wrong spot they
really do they start in the wrong spot
if they would just start with he is a
cult leader Republicans are a cult then
it would be much easier much easier
listen I I listened to a Twitter space
last night and I know I talk about this
a lot but I went into one of Mario's
Twitter spaces last night they wanted me
to speak I actually requested the mic
near the end but I never got to speak
um all I wanted to tell them was no
notes you guys are nuttier than squirrel
turds keep going
there was a few people in there that
were like yeah Biden's gonna be the
nominee there's a few people on the left
quote unquote
um that were saying that but most of the
other people in there were just absolute
batshit crazy they're the Trump
supporters are RFK supporters
Mario I'd love to have you on the show
dude I loved having on the show but your
framing of your stupid little space was
ridiculous
absolutely ridiculous here's here's the
framing of the Twitter space for the
audience the question was who is more
qualified to be President Biden Trump or
RFK
was so what so where's the scientists in
this equation if RFK gets to work his
way in why didn't DeSantis work his way
in that's because they didn't want to
have DeSantis in the discussion they
wanted it all to be Trump trump to Trump
to Trump to Trump trump
and they were all they were praising RFK
and you should hear some of the crazy
ass [__] that RFK and his supporters say
you think you think [__] Trump
supporters are outside their [__]
minds holy [__] okay this one this one
RFK supporter here's what he said he's
like RFK believes and I believe
that the CIA controls the mainstream
media all the people you see on the TV
are controlled by the CIA I'm not
[__] you
these people this is one of their pieces
of their presidential platform
I'm not kidding you
I wouldn't [__] you you're my favorite
turd why would I do that
listen
RFK apparently believes that the CIA are
you following me
the CIA controls
not only the media but the people on the
media on the on the video screen thing
that you got in your living room and
you're in your bedroom and on your hand
in your hand
that CIA controls all of that
what the [__] are you [__] I've never
got a call from the CIA to be quite
honest I'm kind of disappointed now
I'm kind of pissed off to be when I
heard that last night I was really
[__] pissed I was like why haven't I
been brainwashed by the CIA this is
[__]
can someone get the CIA on the phone for
me I wanna I wanna give them a strongly
worded voicemail
I haven't gotten a call from the CIA I
don't know what to tell you I guess I'm
not part of the media the mainstream
media I don't claim to be I'm actually
I'm actually the liberal media I don't
know if you know that but I'm the
liberal media they only say the liberal
media they're not [__] liberal
they're chasing around after profits and
ratings saying stupid crazy [__] having
stupid crazy people on their program
saying absolute absolute lies
but you know I digress
so let's get back
to Trump news because oh boy it's
heating up I'll tell you what in all
these states these states are doing
everything in their damnedest power to
make sure that Donald Trump is not the
nominee it's an it's incredible
California has tried Iowa is trying the
governor the governor of Iowa and I
don't know if you know this too in Iowa
today they're going to sign they're
going to ban Women's Health Care in Iowa
that's that's kind of special boy that
maybe we should pay attention to that
you know what I mean
they're going to ban
Women's Health Care in Iowa today
when the governor signs the bill and
it's an immediate ban
an immediate ban
listen I'm not going to play their
stupid [__] game
where they say they say abortion and
they say how many weeks you're Banning
Women's Health Care [__]
that's how we should frame it that's how
we should say it that's how we should
come after it and because the majority
of women even conservative women in Iowa
do not want you to [__] ban women's
health care it's not a [__] thing
we've seen it in Kansas we've seen in
Kentucky Michigan Idaho they all had
referendums
even in these conservative states who
voted
in the election to for the people who
would place the ban on women's health
care it's Women's Health Care period
period
stop saying the abortion word
and ain't got nothing to do with that
it's about banning Women's Health Care
period
if you don't [__] like it [__] you
[__] yeah I I don't I don't care that's
women's you're Banning Women's Health
Care
okay we gotta get our language straight
we got to get our messaging straight
here
but also in Iowa with with Governor
Reynolds she's a [__] box oh my God
she's a [__] shitbox that governor of
Iowa
here's the thing
apparently Reynolds is trying to hedge
her bits right she really really wants
Ron DeSantis to be
to to be the nominee and the reason why
is because Kim Reynolds loves the word
woke too like she loves the word woke
like like Ron DeSantis wants to [__] the
word woke okay it's Insanity these two
are like peas in a fascist pod
Kim Reynolds and Ron DeSantis but she
has this problem see Trump trump
endorsed her and basically went and
rallied for her in Iowa and got her
elected the way he sees it you know I
don't know if that's the truth or not I
actually don't think Trump gets anyone
elected
I I think them I think them supporting
Trump gets them elected not he gets them
elected do you follow me you know this
this um this party versus ideology [__]
is getting a lot way out of hand right
it's getting way out of hand most
Americans believe that parties are
ideology and they're not okay part
parties we have we only have two in this
country and if you're in another party
if you're like I'm a Libertarian you're
just you're just [__] yourself is
all you're doing libertarian isn't an
actual party you know that right
Libertarians don't want to do government
so why would they get elected to
government that's really [__] dumb
your party is useless why do you think
Libertarians don't get elected to [__]
because they can't govern because they
refuse to they it's their whole [__]
platform is oh you want government elect
someone else
okay makes sense so when someone tells
you like when they look you in the face
you're like well I'm a Libertarian
that's just a fancy way of saying well I
still want to be a bigot to some degree
to some degree I still want to be a
bigot okay to some degree because I I
want to pick and choose what big
government things that I can call big
government okay that's why I'm a
Libertarian but this it doesn't really
exist right now there's ideology
which ideology is completely different
than party affiliation completely
different
I mean there's there's a lot of people
in in the Democratic party that I do not
agree with their ideology do not and
they definitely don't [__] believe
with in mine
they definitely do not align with mine
but that's okay we all have our own
right
it's like what I was talking about
yesterday was social media and the
algorithms do you remember this
yesterday I told you look if you are
looking and you're going to threads as
as the most uh recent example
if you're going to threads to find a
social media Oasis where you can bathe
in social media that you just love every
single piece every single Post in your
thread
in your timeline is something that you
enjoy then then you need to get the [__]
off social media you're just not going
to find a social media Oasis and the
reason why is because each individual
person on social media threads Instagram
Facebook Twitter whatever the [__] it is
Tick Tock we all all of us each
individual account has our own algorithm
that we've built to feed us the [__]
that the algorithm thinks we want
or don't want or are things that might
enjoy right so you got what is there 110
120 million users on threads now I think
something like that oh 100 million let's
just say there's 100 million
right 100 million uh accounts on dread
so there's a hundred million algorithms
all ramming into each other right
colliding into each other
it's the same thing in our country with
politics it's the same thing you have
your political beliefs you have your
political stance you fall on which side
almost interested I'm an independent I'm
a moderate well I'm a progressive I'm a
liberal I'm a socialist you know what I
mean I'm a Nazi no that's going around
the lot here lately especially on
Twitter I'm going to show you some today
oh man
baby these Nazis are everywhere on
Twitter and they're proud of it they're
so excited that they finally have a
mainstream platform to post their Nazi
[__] on it's amazing
but we're all colliding out here in this
universe
so we have to understand this we have to
understand that each individual is not
going to compute exactly with us right
you've seen me Texas Paul is going to be
on today you've seen me in Texas Paul
disagree and and I don't think we have
the exact same political stance on
things I don't I don't think that we
would Advocate exactly the same when it
comes to every single little line item
in every single issue but that doesn't
matter
it doesn't matter because I believe that
Paul believes in democracy
I believe that Paul is pro-democracy I
know he is I'm pro-democracy
there are certain parts of our ideology
that we agree on and we should live in
that space we should live in that space
and we should learn learn
to love
to love we should learn to love and if
Paul has a different opinion on me on
something else well I should love him
for the [__] that he agrees with me on I
don't have to agree with him on
everything he doesn't have to agree with
me
and that's just one example of this
universe where 100 million people are
colliding right
and that's what we have to understand
about this
which brings me back to the RFK thing oh
my God
so
there's a lot of confusion amongst some
on the left because RFK is a is it has
always been his entire life a huge
climate activist right huge climate
activist I I think he'll probably
continue to be a climate activist I
actually take him at his word on that
issue
as crazy as that may seem but the
problem is I think RFK is either being
paid or he's got a [__] brain worm
okay he's got a q Anon brain worm
you cannot tell me that it is that it is
any kind of rational thought or that you
would want someone in the White House
who believes that the CIA listen to me
listen to me turn it up if you need to
RFK apparently believes that the CIA
controls the media and all the
personalities on the media this is some
wild [__]
and the reason why he's saying this is
because the media is questioning him
because he's a [__] bonehead he's a
liar
he peddles in misinformation
he literally is using his [__] name
and his platform to Peddle
misinformation to propel him to fandom
to Maga
you got it and he's doing it by being a
Democrat which is better than anything
else he could ever imagine
this is the same stupid [__] that
Candace Owens does with black people
that's right I said it I don't give a
[__] if you hate me for it that's what
she does it's what Herschel Walker did
it's the same thing
to pretend to pretend that he's some
sort of [__] liberal Warrior get the
[__] out of here with this nonsense
listen liberalism does not peddle
[__] lies liberalism does not running
a run around peddling [__] lies
that's just not what it does
it doesn't need to
when you give someone the ability to
make a choice an opportunity to make a
choice which is the definition of
liberalism when you give people the
opportunity to make a choice
you don't need to Peddle misinformation
and lies when you're looking when you're
looking to control folks
when you're looking to control what
their thoughts are you don't give them
choices there's only one choice and it's
that everyone who's not me is against me
sounds familiar doesn't it sounds
familiar
all's RFK Jr is doing is doing mini
trumpism from the Democratic side and
it's gonna it's gonna work he's gonna
get some support
my guess is is that RFK is going to run
in this election
he he's gonna try to get on an
independent ballot in a few States he'll
probably be successful to get on an
independent ballot in a few States
because he's trying to help Trump is
what he's trying to do because
ultimately he loves Trump he loves that
style of populism
is what he loves and it's called grift
populism
it it he loves it RFK Jr loves grip
but he's gonna do it in 2028 too
right he's gonna do it and he's he's I'm
telling you in 2028 it's gonna be a
banger
and I'm not saying that we should not
[__] keep perpetuating rfkg we should
we should now this is a different
conversation in a different timeline but
RFK JR could really help Gavin Newsom
get elected in 2028.
he really could oh my God
thinking that the CIA controls the
mainstream meet Jesus [__] Christ he
believes frogs are gay Chemtrails what
else Alex Jones what else do you believe
but again folks I tell you ideology does
not mean party you need to stop that
nonsense
we don't have to be loyal to the
Democratic party right you don't have to
be loyal to it to know that they're the
same ones
to know that they're the ones that you
should be voting for because the
Republican party is absolutely crumbling
underneath the [__] Foundation that
doesn't exist in trumpism
they're crumbling underneath their own
lines this morning I've seen Ron Johnson
and several others trying to justify
that their fake ass whistleblower
somehow is being oppressed now oh this
is the bidens trying to cover up the
Whistleblower well we already know your
lies about The Whistleblower so what are
they trying to cover up
they would have indicted him months ago
months ago before you brought him up
inside the public space to cover it up
what the [__] are you talking about
cover it up a cover-up you try to get it
to where no one knows
you can't talk sense into these dumb
[__] you just can't but we're
gonna try we're gonna try right here on
the Tony Michaels podcast I'm glad
you're joining me on a Tuesday because
you know it's Taco Tuesday and it's
Texas Paul Tuesday we got Texas Paul
here with you so do not forget do not
forget to subscribe to the Tony Michaels
podcast right here on YouTube click
subscribe it's [__] free it's free to
subscribe here on YouTube and we provide
this show for you free every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific for two
full hours you can also watch it on
Facebook if you're looking for somewhere
else to watch it at the Tony Michaels
follow us on Facebook also if you want
to follow us on meta
go to the Tony Michaels on meta I'm
going to show you something I discovered
this yesterday
you cannot interact
with threads
on your web browser but you can view it
you can view it I didn't know this I'm
going to show it to you today I'm going
to show you this we'll talk a little bit
about threads because I want to ask
Texas Paul about thread see what he
thinks so far it's been it's been not
quite a week yet not quite a week what
has it been five days six days some [__]
like that I'm gonna talk to Texas Paul
about that we're also going to talk
about fonnie Willis
and the Georgia grand jury that's gonna
crawl right up Donald Trump's ass and
live in there
we're also going to talk about is Judge
Cannon going to punt the trial yes she
is is she gonna punt the trial past the
election and then I also that the my
pillow guy apparently is losing his
business we want to talk about that
today so don't go anywhere we're going
to talk about that and also
I don't know any everyone keeps
spreading around this Britney Spears
video where she's going to do an
announcement and she's dancing around I
think everyone's got the wrong idea
about this video I'm gonna show you the
video I know it's not politics but hey
we got to have a little fun here and I I
actually I will I want I couldn't stop
watching this video and I I am I am
happy and I'm so glad that Britney is
being her that is exactly what Britney
should do exactly exactly what you
should do is do you don't go anywhere
we'll be right back right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard in blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show it's Tuesday
Tuesday taco Tuesday we got it going on
here
hot Dance I'm gonna give you a few more
plugs here I want to give a shout out to
all the people over on Twitch we haven't
been over to the chat on Twitch get your
ass over there and try it out just go to
twitch.tv that's twitch.tv slash the
Tony Michaels get over there and check
out the twitch chat you can follow us
there for free
it costs money to subscribe over on
Twitch but it's free to find I know it's
weird because YouTube it's free to
subscribe but on Twitch it's follow they
should all get on the same page all
these social media and streaming sites
should get on that they're not gonna get
on the same page they're not going to
get on the same page Texas Paul they're
just not gonna do it my friend I am glad
to have you here on this Tuesday I am
glad to be here my friend I am glad to
be here I have a big fan of yours with
me here today she's my new she's my new
co-host I want to introduce you to her
yeah if you don't mind she loves your
work she loves what oh really beats yeah
she beats the living [__] out of
right-wing narratives yeah for a living
that's what she does
[Laughter]
it sounds like she's gonna hit some home
runs
so let me ask you something you know
speaking of social media well you know
let's start off with this this threads
thing before we get into the news uh
because um I did several people have
asked me about threads and when I think
about threads and I I didn't ask me
anything on my patreon yesterday and we
talked a little bit about threads but
what's your take what's your take on
threads we haven't got a chance to talk
about it yet because this kind of
happened last week after the holiday you
you were actually the one who was like
hey man are you on thread yet I'm like
what the [__] is threads like I had no
clue I I was on I was on vacation I
turned everything off I wasn't paying
attention but you were the one who cued
me in on threads and I went immediately
and got an account
uh you know man what you were talking
about earlier love it that's exactly
what I think about threads you're gonna
you're gonna have everybody on threads
but what doesn't happen on threads is
that [__] I don't want to see you know I
I if you want opposing views on threads
you have to go get them or somebody that
you follow has to link them into you I
am not getting eye raped on a daily
basis by freaking cat turd okay a guy I
don't follow a guy that you know it's
just not freaking happening I love the
algorithm on threads because it is what
social media was supposed to be so far
so far you like that algorithm on
threads because I I think that's I think
that's the um the misnomer is that a
person's gonna go to any social media
platform any of them no matter how new
how old and be able to be able to get
their algorithm in a way that they won't
see something that they that they don't
like right you know what I mean I mean
you're you're gonna see something that
you're like oh well I don't like that
and the reason why is because you're
following accounts that post things like
you're you're how many followers you got
now on threads you got uh one 20 30 30
000 okay so there's gonna be in that
thirty thousand you're gonna post
something on threads that not every
single one of those thirty thousand
people agree with you see what I mean
guaranteed yeah right exactly there's
gonna be something that you they don't
agree with right and there's gonna be
something that the people you follow
that will post that you don't agree with
that I mean again there's a lot of
things out there that people that I
follow that I that I respect that I
think are are are like-minded in
liberalism I don't agree with everything
that they say I don't agree with
everything they tweet so you can't get
yourself in a situation where you think
you're gonna develop this this uh bubble
right but Twitter look at the Cattail
nice speaking of cat turds there's cat
tail
so listen the thing though is is that I
think what threads is ultimately gonna
do and I know this is a long shot and I
think this is a long way off threads
because of competition is actually going
to help fix Twitter to some degree and
maybe maybe Twitter crashes and burns I
don't know the traffic is absolutely
tanked all the sycophants for Twitter
are trying to act like it's some sort of
thing that it's not but what do you
think what do you do what do you how do
you think threads affects Twitter
ultimately
I think that Twitter becomes the
freaking hellscape that Elon Musk wanted
it to be it's going to be his personal
Echo chamber he's going to end up having
to dump his own money into it to keep it
alive because it's it its engagements
are just have tanked complete he pissed
so many people off that we now like Mark
Zuckerberg again I mean that's how bad
it was easy easy
and I don't know I wouldn't use the word
like all right to answer your question
Tony the future of Twitter in in my view
is that it just keeps distilling down to
this Nazi [__] right-wing dystopian
view that Elon Musk thought the world
was and
it collapses because financially you
can't run a social media platform on
that you just you just can't I mean
it'll end up being like true social that
where you get all those grips and stuff
going on all the time and that's what
it'll become a shadow of of itself but
he won't sell it and he won't let it die
because he's too arrogant
right so it'll never be revived I'm glad
you brought up true social because I
mean I could see in the near future in
the next 18 24 months especially in the
lead-up to the election that Twitter
becomes what true social was intended to
be right because true social true social
is all [__] over there it's just a
space where Grandpa can [__] post and
then a couple hundred thousand people
can interact with him it's not an actual
social media platform there's not
engagement on there it's all [__]
all the ads are true true social uh fake
ass ads it's not real it's just a fake
ass it's a fraud just like everything
else he does and it's only for him to
post on social media that's it full stop
but but Twitter could become that and
let me let me show you something here
this this this post is going around
Twitter today this this [__] [__]
here
um and a lot of people including me are
quote tweeting him
um this was posted several days ago it's
it he says now again
take stock of who this is right okay are
you following me you got the energy
you're in all right he says all men who
follow Nick Fuentes need to be built
like this white men unite we must
continue our race Jews cannot be allowed
to destroy our culture and Heritage this
is what they see
as the master Superior race this guy
right there the face you see on the
screen is considered to be a great white
follower of Nick Fuentes now if you
don't know Nick Fuentes is which I know
you know Paul but for the audience who
doesn't know Nick Fuentes is a Nazi
um he is a not self about selfish
he's the guy for all of you who don't
know he's the guy who went around with
Kanye West he was the Entourage with
Kanye West for Kanye West to go around
to Alex Jones to uh to several other
right-wing podcasts and say
I love Hitler I love Hitler and Hitler
did great things that's what Kanye West
did he destroyed his and his entire
image his entire career over those
little words and Nick Fuentes was the
one who helped facilitate that by
marching him around to all these
right-wing podcasts that's who Nick
Fuentes is and this guy thinks
that he is the image of what Nick
Fuentes is looking for which is kind of
pathetic I want to give you one take on
it this is one of my favorite accounts
it's becoming one of my favorite
accounts on Twitter to be honest with
you especially when she gets in replies
she does not hold back with these
[__] it says uh Death Angel
says the master race needs to be built
like they fly out of a window of a
moving car like a McDonald's napkin are
you kidding me this is this is what you
think is a master race you're a dumb
[__] and he looks like I'm [__] I don't
know anything about this guy but I will
tell you and you know me I'm like the
the better everybody everybody you know
that does better the better off we are
so right this is not in any way a
homophobic comment
but I will tell you this guy appears to
me to be a closeted guy who's definitely
peeled the foreskin back before and just
is a self-loathing self-hating Nazi
that's what when I see that picture of
him taking his shirt off for people and
wanting to be noticed to me he's
trolling for dates that's what I'm
picking up and I don't mean that in any
good way I mean Hey Hey Hey listen
everybody does better when everybody
does better and God live your life man
see us do what you don't hate on people
do what you're gonna do sis if you like
if you like men hey just do men that's
it listen here's what I said and I think
this is the most important thing if you
go look at this guy's profile and don't
be scared to go look at it that's the
other thing that really pisses me off
about this and and I know they've been
doing it on threads because they want to
dampen down uh the Nazi talk over on
threads by blocking all these people but
here's here's what I'll tell you is that
if if we absolutely allow them to have
their own Echo chamber they are going to
get louder and louder and louder and
louder in their Echo chamber listen the
problem that we have right now is not
that neo-nazism exists it it is it has
existed for a long time the problem is
is that they are making it mainstream
because we are helping them do that okay
we are helping them do that because
they're going to do anything to own the
libs and if and if us being offended
that they exist listen if we're offended
by that and we absolutely cannot handle
that these hateful bigots exist and we
can't do the proper thing which is mock
them and tell them that you are wrong
and you are piece of [__] and you are a
piece of garbage and you don't do not
belong in modern society if we don't do
that to them openly then they will exist
but here's what I said here's what I
said I said it's important to go look at
this account and take stock of who he
idolizes people out there claiming
Republicans aren't Nazis are full-on
[__] some Maga might think they
aren't Nazis but the Nazis think
if you go look at his profile on Twitter
and you look at the people that he's
retweeting the people that he's
commenting the people that he's liking
the [__] that he's engaging with
it's not [__] Neo-Nazi I hate Jews
stuff all the time it is but it's not
all the time it's this slow walk to
DeSantis being their Idol to Trump being
their Idol folks the reason why they
love the scientists and the reason why
they love Trump more than they love
DeSantis is because Trump lets them be
this
without saying you should not be that
you shouldn't do that dummy you
shouldn't that's gross that's disgusting
you're a Nazi
Trump will not call Nazis Nazis and if I
can run with that Tony just for a second
I will tell you I am looking right at
you audience I'm looking right at you do
you know why this exists you did this
not them on the right they've always
wanted to be this we let this happen we
were high-minded we stuck to the high
road we didn't tell them you know what
you're an idiot you're a jerk you're I
mean just you don't have to cuss you
don't have to be as Brazen as I am as
Tony is you know but
you have to speak up for too long we
said we're not going to engage in that
politics and look what happened you have
half of white men out there half of
white men out there that have a head
full of [__] because they've sat there
and listened to this Echo chambers that
Tony's talking about lived in it and
nobody ever told them that's the
stupidest [__] I've ever heard
you know they've never had the pushback
that's why they freak out so bad on
people like me and people like Tony you
know because they're like
you said that to me yeah I said it to
you you need to say it to them when your
crazy uncle is sitting across from you
in a few months of Thanksgiving and
goddamn thanksgiving's only a few months
away not that far away yeah I mean when
you're sitting across the table from him
you need to looking dead in the eye and
say that's the stupidest [__] I've ever
heard and when he says well what do you
think no no I'm not going to argue with
you because that will validate your
stupid [__] but it's the stupidest [__]
I've ever heard right well when you look
at your uncle uh when you look at your
Uncle Eddie across the table you say
Uncle Eddie that's some nazi-ass [__]
that's some Nazi ass [__] that you're
saying that's some crazy not to ass [__]
speaking of Nazi as [__] there's a
sitting United States senator from
Alabama that apparently loves white
nationalism he's a white nationalist he
loves it he thinks a white nationalists
are American Patriots or some [__] did
you see this clip Texas yeah thank you
holy [__] well that that was the whole
transition was to get to the Tommy tuber
real thing
um because that other guy that other
brainless idiot that's on Twitter that
posted his stupid
um side muscle thing or whatever with
his stupid look on his face thinking
he's the master race he's a nobody he's
a nobody but this guy is a sitting
United States senator from Alabama folks
that's there's a big difference and I
know I know um you know a lot of people
might you know get at me to say well
Tony Tommy tuberville isn't any better
than this person this person he's been
better than Tommy Jupiter that may be
true but Tommy two reveal holds a hell
of a lot of power
and the people of Alabama gave him a
hell of a lot of power in an election
knowing that he's a dumb [__] I
mean this guy is just not all there but
listen to how he describes white
nationalists and white nationalism
conservatives Democrats whoever wants to
be in the uh the the military to fight
for this country to protect this country
that's what it's all about but just to
be clear you agree that white
nationalists should not be serving in
the U.S military is that what you're
saying if if people think that a white
nationalist is a racist I agree with
that I agree white nationalist is
someone who believes that the white race
is superior to other races well that's
some people's opinion no no no no Tommy
no time no Tommy to two branches did you
know that Tommy Tommy tubreel could only
name two branches of government did you
know that I wish I could find that clip
what a [__] idiot this guy didn't
even know there's three branches of
government he didn't know the three
branches he's in one of them but here's
the thing is it Tommy tuberville
believes Texas Paul he says here on CNN
in front of the world that he believes
that that it's an opinion that white
nationalists are racist what the actual
how in the [__] did we get in a spot
where United States Senator doesn't know
the definition of white nationalism how
is that even possible
you know
call it like it is Tony
white guys down in in Alabama have
rigged a vote they've gerrymandered and
it doesn't matter for a senator's vote I
know but they will close voting polling
places where predominantly black voters
vote
and then they will go and elect a racist
ass jackass like Tommy Tommy tuberville
that lives in freaking Florida
doesn't even live in Alabama lives in
freaking Florida
they will elect that [__] because they
want to be a racist jackass because
their heads have been crammed full of
crap that's that's that's what it is
that's what it is it's he is what
Alabama wanted now I'm not insulting
everybody from Alabama saying uh
everybody from Allen bam is a Tommy
tuberville no they are not there there's
a large chunk of the population that are
enlightened people that that think like
I do everybody does better when
everybody does better but there are a
big enough chunk of Tommy tubbervilles
in freaking Alabama that this is what we
got and he's using his this idiotic rule
in the Senate that a senator any Senator
can place a hold on promotions
any one Senator can place a hold and the
Senate has to respect that hold
that Rule's got to go Tony that has got
to go that's just been abused by
Republicans for so long that they need
to lose it they need to lose it they
really do I know Democrats are saying
well we don't want to lose that right
when we're well Republicans aren't going
to respect your right they're not
the minute they want to push people in
well that Rule's going to go that's
right remember remember when they wanted
a Supreme Court Justice remember that
yeah I remember let's finish here
because he digs a bigger hole because
she just she keeps handing him a bigger
shovel which honestly is what you should
do this is I'm surprised by this
interview to be quite honest because
normally they would just kind of leave
it at whoa that was some wild [__] so
we'll be back with some more wild [__]
with another wild Republican here in
just a minute to espouse their lies and
[__] on our network but she doesn't
do that she actually hands him a bigger
shovel watch this uh and I don't think I
mean a lot
pardon what's your opinion my opinion of
a white nationalist if somebody wants to
call them white Nash to me is an
American it's an American now if that
white nationalist is a racist I'm
totally against anything that they want
to do because I am 110 Against Racism
but I want somebody no he's not in our
military that's strong that believes in
this country that's an American that
will fight along anybody whether it's a
man or woman black or white red it
doesn't make any difference uh and and
so I'm totally against identity politics
I think it's ruining this country and I
think that Democrats ought to be ashamed
for how they're doing this because it's
dividing this country and it's making
this country weaker every day okay so
Texas Paul I noticed something about
Tommy tuberville in this in this
interview someone someone I don't know
who it is I don't know if it's someone
on a staff I don't know if it's a donor
I don't know who it is but someone's
prepping him for these questions okay
and the reason why is because Tommy 2
reveal tries to Pivot from white
nationalists or not racist to its
identity politics and its Democrats
fault right he tries to Pivot he does a
really shitty job of pivoting a better
way of saying it for Tommy's sake and
Tommy if you're listening here was how
you would transition I'm not talking
about white nationalism as racist or not
racist I'm talking about the identity
politics that Democrats do all the time
Democrats continue the identity politics
to make every white person in the
military white nationalists that would
be the proper way to transition Tommy
that would be the proper way if you
wanted to espouse your misinformation
and your and your [__] racism but he
does a bad job here the reason why I
point that out Texas Paul is because
Tommy is doing all this holding up bills
in the Senate with with the military and
really hurting hurting actual human
beings in the military not not
necessarily hurting the military in
general I mean it is put on a NASA
security at risk but more he's hurting
human beings like this [__]
Senator is hurting human beings okay now
he's doing it because someone's paying
him to do it
that's my view of it is he's got a donor
saying this is what I want you to do
yeah he's got a donor that's got like a
secret Nazi closet in the back of their
hallway you know what I mean a
billionaire like Harlan Crowe or
somebody's paying this guy to do this
because the and let's be honest about it
the stuff he's espousing today is
complete crap it's complete crap he's
trying to say well this is about
abortion in the military and I warned
him this was coming bull [__] this
started over this white supremacy stuff
right the the the military said we're
going to root out we have a white
supremacy problem and we're going to
root it out because of people like Jack
to Shara
who are being freaking Traders
because they're racist jackasses that
that have bought into this the
Republican is the racist Valhalla party
and therefore I have to you know try to
destroy Democrats and and all of the
freaking motives that these white
supremacists racists have
the military said we can't have this we
we just can't we've got to root this out
we can't operate this way
Tommy toberville said you can't get rid
of my racists in the military that's our
base right that's our base you can't do
that well I don't think Tommy I don't
think he came up with that on his own I
think I think someone came up that with
him for him he they're just using him as
the vehicle
well you're talking about people
prepping him right that's when he
pivoted to well this is about abortion
in the military because nobody said a
damn word about Reproductive Rights in
the military before tummy Tommy
tuberville got caught like a deer in the
headlights on national news defending
white supremacy in our military then all
of a sudden it it pivoted to being about
well you got to say this is about
abortion right so that's the only thing
well that's that's that's always their
stick isn't it that's always their stick
it's always about abortion isn't it I
mean in Iowa today Kim Reynolds the
governor in Iowa is going to ban Women's
Health Care ban Women's Health Care in
Iowa when when the majority of women in
Iowa do not want her to [__] ban
Women's Health Care and they're going to
do it she's going to sign that [__] and
that [__] that law is going to
be enforced immediately no it's not
going to be waiting period there's not
gonna be some weighty beer now hopefully
someone [__] gets it adjudicated in a
court quickly and gets a stop on this
[__] so that women in Iowa have
a chance to get the health care that
they should receive
but I'm telling you I'm telling you
folks I'm telling you that this [__]
white nationalist abortion [__] just
like Texas Paul is saying it's all one
and the same it's all one and the same
if they're out there pushing this
[__] anti-abortion and they want to
take away women's right to health care
it's because they're a white nationalist
it's white supremacy you [__]
just go look at that little twits feed
on Twitter that I showed you who thinks
he's one of Nick Fuentes his great white
fans I'm telling you and I believe I bet
that guy would love Tommy do you real
and what else he says in this interview
and you didn't write it on the head
because the anti-abortion movement is
rooted in white supremacy absolutely
well you're just killing black babies
they don't give a damn about black
babies what they did was they looked at
the math they looked at the math and
said white people aren't having babies
anymore like they used to there's a lot
of one child or dinks out there do dual
income no kids white couples out there
and they are not reproducing they said
we can't lose a single one of these kids
to abortion we can't well
well Jerry Falwell Jr found out real
quick that they couldn't use race as a
cudgel and that they had to use
something else and they could actually
pin up the abortion and really drive a
wedge through race yeah and you've got
like
you've got Hispanic families black
families Asian families all of these
families are still traditional larger
families
three kids four kids five kids I can't
you know you don't have families like I
grew up in Tony I don't know how many
you grew up in there were five kids in
my little German Irish family
you don't have that anymore you just
don't and they're freaking out about it
and that's the white supremacy [__]
behind this anti-abortion movement well
it's exactly exactly what I showed you
on that [__] little Twigs tweet he
said the the white race must continue
they're trying to get rid of our white
way that's the whole thing well but I
bet that little Nazi on Twitter would
love what else uh tuberville has to say
here so let's listen to the end where he
really throws dirt on his grave but that
that's not identity politics you said a
white nationalist is an American it is
identity politics you said a white
nationalist is an American but a white
nationalist is someone who who believes
horrific things you don't do you really
think that's someone who should be
serving in the military well that's just
a name that has been given I mean it's
not it's real it's a real definition
there's Real Construction so if you're
going to do away with most white people
in this country out of the military we
got huge problems it's not people who
are white it's white nationalists that
have a few probably different beliefs
right they have that have different
beliefs now if racism is one of those
beliefs I'm totally against it I am
totally Against Racism
is racist Senator well that's your
opinion that's your opinion but if it's
racism if it's racism I'm totally
against it I am totally against any type
of race or any any type of racism I
don't care what it's in
and what he means by that Texas Paul is
I'm against anyone being racist against
white people that's what he means that's
what he means when people are racist
against white people I'm I'm against
that that's what he's saying he's not
actually saying he's not actually saying
that he hates racism because if he was
saying that if he was if that's what he
did truly believe was his opinion he
would be calling out white nationalists
and saying no you goddamn right we
shouldn't have white nationalists
outright white nationalists in our
military and we should we shouldn't
allow them to stay in our military we
should give them a dishonorable
discharge and get them the [__] out of
our goddamn military and the reason why
this is coming up Texas Paul is because
um because Trump was on the Move in 2016
he became the president
um much to the country Chagrin the
majority of the people in the country
did not want him to be the president
United States and it only gave
permission because that's the thing that
she's missing a little bit that Tommy
tuberville is doing too giving people
permission to be white nationalists
giving them permission to continue this
white supremacy [__] and Trump did
that so much so that it was actually it
was actually a really when Tick Tock
came about in 2020 it got really hard
for the military to ignore this because
a lot of the people in the military they
were in their uniforms saying crazy [__]
on Tick Tock I mean there was a lot of
people that I mean there was a whole a
whole group of veterans that would go
around and sniff out these accounts of
these people who were in their uniform
saying this crazy [__] that they're
really not supposed to be saying when
you're in the military
um and and Reporting them to the
superiors and a lot of them were getting
kicked out of the military because of it
um and it's a phenomenon and I forget
exactly what it's called when these
people are finding these people but but
that is a thing that the dod went hey
maybe this is a problem when they're on
social media saying it loudly and
proudly on social media maybe we do have
a problem in our military
yeah I mean you saw it all over I mean
it was the the biggest one was that kid
he was like 19 years old just finished
basic had just moved into his dorm where
for his Technical Training and he's on
tick tock just with the most filthy
horrid you know and you know racist crap
pouring out of his mouth in his uniform
I mean with with his name right there
you know and and
yeah I mean a lot of folks said whoa
we've got a problem here right I've told
I've told you know you've got
conservative Hispanics that are breaking
Republican and I have told my friends
you know me I'm from South Texas man
I I have a lot of conservative Hispanic
friends I do and I have told them
repeatedly you are not welcome in their
Club
you are not welcome in their Club
they'll use you they'll take your vote
but you are not welcome in their club
and they don't believe me they just
don't believe me and I don't get I don't
understand why I'm a middle-aged white
guy that has heard more racist filth
from people that think that that I'm one
of you know I get judged a lot Tony I do
I get the one of the comments I get the
most is wow I never thought you'd be a
liberal you know because they Judge Me
by the way I look I and so do the
racists and they tell me the and you
know they do it to you too Tony oh yeah
you've got those blah and blue eyes and
that blonde hair and you know they walk
up and say the craziest [__] crazy as
[__] and you try to tell people that are
not that are that are black that are
Asian that are Hispanic you're not in
the club you think you're in the club
but you're not in the club and they
don't believe me I don't I don't
understand
I don't understand that
well and again
um it goes back to the whole thing that
I was saying earlier about Candace Owens
and Herschel Walker right it goes back
to that it goes back to that I want to
jump now to uh Chris Christie I want to
show you this uh this clip of Chris
Christie this morning on Morning Joe
Chris Christie's trying to land punches
but I I don't know Chris understands
this or not the more he lands punches on
Trump the less likely he will be the
nominee
It's the funniest thing it's the
funniest thing I think because this this
Republican primary could actually
Deliver us some really good stuff in
this country it could it could deliver a
huge loss for Trump in the general
election proving that this country does
not want that [__] and we did not
play this [__] about lies and
nonsense and traitors and people who
[__] commit dozens of [__]
felonies against us okay number two it's
going to destroy Ron desantis's
political career which I I'm here for
and I'm here to watch I'm here to watch
meatball go down in [__] Flames
that's fantastic I'm gonna show you
another clip on that too maybe but it's
gonna absolutely destroy Chris
Christie's chance of ever ever getting
into office as a republican ever again
ever in the history of ever ever because
the Republican party is absolutely going
to turn against Chris Christie because I
think he's he might make it on the stage
I hope he does I hope Chris Christian
makes it on the stage number one because
I want him to keep destroying DeSantis
and Trump okay number number one but
number two I want him to destroy his
political career as well because as far
as I'm concerned Chris Christie is one
of the most formidable formidable
Republicans still in the Republican
party what I mean by that is Chris
Christie knows politics
he knows it really well and I think he
knows he's not going to win I think he
knows what he's doing here I think he
knows that he's absolutely destroying
his political career but he's going to
go down in history he's going to write a
book after this campaign he's going to
make a lot of money a lot of money off a
lot of money
it's gonna be I I was kicked out of the
Republican party because I'm not with
Trump type book it's going to sell a
shitload on the left a lot of the
audience is going to buy it a lot of
people are going to buy that book and
he's going to make a shitload of money
because I think that's what Chris
Christie's doing but also what Chris
Christie's doing is he's trying to land
punches on Trump and he's he's hasn't I
don't think he's landed a good one yet
but this morning boy he really got a
whiff he got a whiff of Donald Trump's
ass here listen to this listen to this
well I think there's there's serious
legal Jeopardy in terms of being found
guilty do I think he'll be sent to
Rikers Island uh unlikely
the the special prosecutor case is much
much different his content there is
reprehensible
I want people to understand this he was
given 18 months to return those
documents voluntarily 18 months they
asked him privately quietly respectfully
he lied denied and obstructed he
obstructed a grand jury subpoena he lied
to his own lawyers
hid documents from his own lawyers so
that they wouldn't turn over documents
to the government and then even the
documents he gave them he said by the
way you see some bad ones in there pluck
them out before you give them to the
government
okay so Chris Christie laying out laying
out the facts of the indictment right
without without mentioning the
indictment without getting in the weeds
of the indictment he's just laying out
the story that the indictment tells this
is why Jack Smith did the indictment the
way he did at Texas ball this is why I
believe he did it because it tells the
story and Chris Christie's telling the
story here now he's winding up his punch
okay he's winding up but have you seen
this clip yet have you seen this clip of
Chris Christie yet okay good because
because I want your your genuine
interaction when he tries to throw the
punch but what do you think so far of
Chris Christie because Chris Christie
has been working this material for quite
some time you you remember the the uh
the town hall he held when he announced
in New Hampshire he did a little bit of
this but he didn't wind up quite like
this what do you think so far
well the Republic the whole Republican
institution is paid for and funded and
built off 70 year old billionaires okay
um that's why you you couldn't see
um
uh Cheney did nothing because she's a
woman I mean I I don't believe that I'm
not a misogynist I think she's a very
relevant person but in the Republican
establishment this couldn't come from a
woman
Chris Christie absolutely plays with
that group of billionaires that are not
with the Paul singers They're not with
the Ferris wheels they're not with these
radical ass billionaires that have taken
over the Republican Party they're like
uh we need to purge this [__] Chris
Christie is their plunger
you're right Chris Christie knows for a
fact this ends his political career
because what he's doing is he's telling
trumpers you're wrong right and they
cannot hear that and continue to support
you that's just not human nature and and
he knows he's doing it but he's going to
make a ton of money at the other end of
this he has big donors that's why he's
not going away he'll be on that stage
because his mission his paid for mission
is to plunge that giant orange turd down
the toilet
and take the loss that is his job that's
a great visual I like that Vision I mean
that that the other thing I'll tell you
about Chris Christie that some people
may or may not know because a lot of
people know him as the the two-term uh
New Jersey governor of New Jersey and
for bridge gate because that was really
Chris Christie's biggest controversy
other than him yelling and screaming at
reporters like that was one thing that
he did on the daily he would just get
mean with reporters and just get vile
right
um which gets me excited when if he's
going to get mean and vile with Trump
right he hasn't quite got there yet he
hasn't quite got to that Chris Christie
level yet but he's gonna get there I
think but here's the thing is that Chris
Christie was a United States Attorney
Not only was Chris Christie a really
effective United States Attorney and
really good at being a United States
Attorney he put Jared kushner's dad in
prison I don't know if anyone knows that
um also also a fun fact about Chris
Christie is he's been friends with
Donald Trump for over 20 years okay uh
and that the fact that he put Jared
kushner's dad in prison has always had
strain on his and Trump's relationship
but as you remember Chris Christie's
such a friend and Confidant to Donald
Trump that he helped prep Donald Trump
during covid for the 2020 debate so much
so that Chris Christie contracted
Covenant damn near killed him
um so he Chris Christie has been
essentially willing to die for Trump to
be you know Frank and out front about it
but there's so much history here between
uh Chris Christie and Trump but I think
the unique perspective that Chris
Christie brings to this race is number
one he was a governor okay which he can
pound and Pummel Rhonda santis all
[__] day long on the governor point
oh my God he's gonna beat the [__]
adirond DeSantis if Ron DeSantis even
makes it to to to the debates to be
quite honest but number two he brings
this perspective of the United States a
former United States Attorney uh and I
think that's important and he brings a
perspective knowing Donald Trump for two
decades because listen to how he
finishes here right and then ultimately
complains I saw on a a post he put up
yesterday that the the raid on his on
his home was a violation of his fourth
amendment rights well he he generally
has really crappy lawyers so let me give
him a little advice when they get a
court order from a United States
District Court Judge it's not a
violation of your Fourth Amendment
rights and in fact if you had done the
simple thing that I think almost any
other American would have died which
would have been to get the documents
back he wouldn't be prosecuted he's in
big trouble there and if he takes this
case to trial
and he's convicted which based upon what
I've seen in the indictment I believe he
would be
then he's facing jail time because part
of what the Department of Justice has
always done under all of the Attorneys
General that I've seen in my lifetime is
if we offer you a plea which I'm certain
they will and you turn it down and you
take us to trial
and you're convicted that judge is
sending you to jail and I think that's
what he goes to bed every night thinking
every night and all this bravado and
everything else I've known him for 22
years when I was doing these cases in
New Jersey and I would put political
figures in jail
she would say to me I could never do
that I could never go to jail and I'm
telling you no matter what he says no
matter how he's bragging and and going
on and on about him not being afraid he
goes to bed every night thinking about
the sound of that jail cell door climate
closing behind them so the point of all
that Willie is to say when push comes to
shove
I'm not so sure he won't take a plea
okay so Chris Christie winding up there
for the punch and he's doing this for
Donald Trump because he knows Donald
Trump is watching this he knows Donald
Trump is watching it but I think the
most unique thing there in that entire
Diddy the punch that he lands on Donald
Trump now again these are light punches
these aren't hard [__] he's not
holding Donald Trump on the ground and
pounding his face in but the punch that
he lands is the one where Chris Christie
says when I when I was a United States
Attorney in New Jersey and I was
Prosecuting these political prisoners
and I knew Donald Trump back then Donald
Trump would say I can't do it I can't go
to prison that's the punch that he's
Landing because what Chris Christie's
saying is you're a little [__] you're a
little [__] Donald Trump tell me you're
not a little [__] say it you're not a
little [__] let's see it because I I
actually don't believe Trump will take a
plea deal but what do you think what do
you think about this last the ending
with the jail cells
he is very strategically laying out and
he's opening the door for Trump
supporters that that's what that is it's
not meant to be a hard punch Tony right
it's not he is opening the door for
Trump supporters
to tell them as you would speak listen
to the way he speaks that's not Chris
Christie the Chris Christie's got he's a
red-faced pissed off jackass this was
Chris Christie talking to Donald Trump's
supporters as a friend and saying look
the reality is this
it's okay if you let this guy go it's
okay if you back away from him this is
really gonna happen
and he might even take a plea deal folks
you're it's okay for you to go find
somebody else that's why I said Chris
Christie's not your friend
neither is Liz Cheney too many people
were singing their praises don't do that
Chris Christie isn't working for the
good of the country he's being very well
paid to work for the good of the
Republican party because right now
they're facing an extinction level event
here
well absolutely that's my take on it
absolutely well and this morning on Fox
News
um they're even trying to find a quick
replacement for Ron DeSantis to be the
number two uh Donald Trump wants Vivek
you know I'm talking about vivec they
want Vivek drama Swami Rama Swami they
want Vivek to be the number two and the
reason why is because vivek's in the
race for Trump I don't know if you know
that he's in the race for Trump he's
he's it's designed for him to be the
number two my guess is that Donald Trump
will only debate Vivek that's my guess
in a Republican primary the only person
that you'll see Donald Trump debate is
Vivek and the reason why is because
Vivek is under there under Trump's
position but this morning on Fox News
they're really [__] they're getting
frustrated with the Santos because he's
a weirdo right and he just can't get off
the ground so much so that he got his
weirdo what right he got his weirdo wife
to try to stunt for him and she's just
as weird as he is the whole world's like
Barbie
so the whole world's like oh Rhonda
Santos is a [__] weirdo let's try his
wife and they're like whoa she's just as
much or more of a weirdo speaking of
weirdos
um we got uh Gabe Sanchez in the uh and
Tucker Carlson
uh how how's Decker Studio there Gabe
you got canned area again again here
your mic's not working and listen Tucker
has a lot of uh technical difficulties
uh in his studio so it's not surprising
that Gabe gets uh that's what you get
for using Tucker students I know it's
gonna be crap and then there you are
you're stuck with it yeah I can't hear
you no I can't hear you no your mic's
not working dude I wish he could get the
hell out of here
[Laughter]
okay so let's go to this clip of Rhonda
santis
um on Fox not Rhonda Santa's on Foxy's
they're talking about Ron DeSantis but
listen to who they're trying to get to
come along and save the Republican Party
look listen to their DeSantis
replacement here Texas ball this is this
is hilarious now some GOP strategists
are suggesting other Republicans enter
the ring one of them is Virginia
governor Glenn youngin who will join us
live for an exclusive interview next
so they got Glenn young and off screen
right look at him look at him right here
oh
they're like which weirdo are we gonna
place with another weirdo let's see if
we can see if we can get Gabe Sanchez's
take on this let's see let's try your
mind try it out are we good oh we got
him we got him finally yeah that was
weird I don't know did Tucker Tucker he
figured he figured out your your audio
during the show if anyone looks back
here and you see a couple eyes Peep
Behind it's Tucker Oh okay but he got
your audio figurehead that's good that's
good well look at this look at this so
on Fox news this morning like oh my God
Rhonda Santos is such a weirdo we need
to find someone to replace him in the
race let's bring in Governor weirdo 2.0
like why in the [__] would they think
that Glenn Younkin is not gonna be as
weird as Rhonda it almost does it like
the way the angle that the camera has
the screen with him on it here once
almost looks
it almost looks like it's not real right
and he can't get looking over like he's
looking over at someone like am I on the
air am I on air am I on air it looks
like the robot that gave the side eye
during that press conference last week
that's what it looks like
Junkin has a Mike dewine problem you
know everybody thought Mike dewine the
governor of Ohio might be a backup in
case everything imploded yeah but then
somebody actually took a look at Mike
dewine and
you know how did this guy get elected
governor I mean he looks like a little
sweaty wet nerd that doesn't have air
conditioning in his mom's basement and
you know junkins know better I mean he's
no better I mean how do these guys get
elected I I don't I don't
know CRT CRT that's that's how young got
elected white supremacy
that's how you do it well you want to
win an election
that's what you got to do get out of it
okay so I'm gonna go to some important
news that now that we have Gabe Sanchez
here this is this is pressing okay so we
all know the story of Britney Spears
yes I'm gonna do the Britney Spears
thing why you're why you're here
um and I've been waiting for you to come
on to do the Britney Spears video now
there's a Britney Spears video that she
posted she posted this on her account
this is not like someone took it off her
phone and hacked yeah yeah it's got 20
is by elon's numbers it's got almost 22
million views so it's 22 million
impressions which is a lot
it's a lot of Impressions okay now I I
saw this how many views it actually is
yeah yeah yeah tell us how many because
you you got a little thing that you can
go in and yeah yeah I'll look it up as
you're talking so here's the thing I
watched a lot of people make a lot of
comments about this video and say that
Britney Spears is off a rocker and she's
crazy and you know yada yada yada on and
on and on now I couldn't stop watching
this video this morning I couldn't stop
watching it number one I don't know if
anyone knows this but I was in junior
high in high school when Britney Spears
came on the scene so she was like the
she was the [__] like that's what every
young boy wanted was Britney Spears then
right because she was she was the hot of
the hot of the hot on music in in in sex
symbols it was just the thing for middle
school and high school boys so there's
that probably when I'm watching this
video
but the thing is is that the story that
goes that she's finally been granted her
Freedom right free Brittany there was a
big movement she's finally been freed
and a lot of people are now questioning
should she be I'm like what about this
video tells you that she shouldn't be or
that somehow somehow this is bad this is
a bad thing I actually don't think this
is a bad thing I'm not gonna play the
music here because it will probably get
knocked on it uh so I'm going to meet
you you can't play it without the music
Tony come on man all right there's just
a bunch of dudes talking while a woman's
dangerous hey what's wrong with that
okay so you see Brittany here this is
actually Britney Spears when I first saw
this I didn't know if it was her or not
I had no idea you know with AI and that
kind of [__] you [__] how you supposed
to know right but then I was like no she
actually
she actually posts this on her social
media this is her she's dancing in what
appears to be her dining room kitchen or
whatever her dog's there she's got like
a torn ass napkin on the floor which is
kind of weird
um and she's dancing in Rhonda Santos
boots a bikini bottom and a white shirt
now let's let's watch this and I'll play
the music let's watch a little bit of it
yeah
okay so some people are like whoa what
the hell is this listen if you've ever
watched a Britney Spears music video
This is what it is okay the only
difference is there's not high
production there's not the video cameras
and the [__] lights and the the
background and all the settings backup
dancers right
it's just her doing her music video for
her cell phone what the [__] what the
[__] is so weird about this I I can't
figure it out game Sanchez what the [__]
is the weird I think it has to do with
the fact so before her uh
conservatorship was was taken back right
she wasn't under the control of her
father uh and the handlers
she would do these videos on her social
media she would do them on Instagram and
it was like more or less her only kind
of like like dancing videos like this
just just like you're watching right now
okay the videos that she would put out
I'm not a big follower Britney Spears so
I I just seen this come up in my head
you got to be educated man right no go
ahead go ahead I that's what I'm looking
for I'm looking for no I'm I am a
50-something white guy so of course I am
just stuck to everything Brittany does
by the way he makes that bikini you can
buy that bikini
okay well I mean you know a lot of
people say that she doesn't look as good
as she did when she was in her 20s I
mean I don't look as good as I did I did
when I was in my 20s so what though you
should have just seen the look I got
from Mrs Texas Paul
hold in here oh God damn putting laser
eyes through you son of a [__] but
here's the thing go go ahead keep going
keep going Gabe keep going keep trying
to keep trying to apologize for
interrupting you date Gabe
keep trying to keep us on track here so
we're not yeah yeah sorry sorry my
internet's a little wonky I'm I'm
watching the chat people are making fun
of my shirt for some reason who the [__]
what what do you guys talk whatever
whatever I like your shirt man this
isn't you know it kind of matches it
kind of matches Britain it kind of
matches Britney's swimming suit if you
want to know the honest
somebody said this is uh it was I think
they said Sears discount rack this is
[__] a this is a penguin shirt dog
whatever anyway y'all be hating I'll be
hating
so here she is on the floor she does a
lot of crazy [__] so so she would she
would
she would make these videos all the time
it's nothing really new the only
difference is the fact that she is you
know quote unquote independent now and
she's free as in the free Britney
movement
she's free yes now a lot of people might
be like oh she looks like out there and
she looks a little stressed or whatever
I could tell you that I could tell you
for a fact one I cannot do this dance
routine uh I would struggle oh wait wait
wait wait hey hey I I would bet a lot of
people would pay money to see that
I'm just saying but I also for you to
try it not to accomplish it that's right
oh yeah yeah you gotta pay me some money
if you want there's some I guarantee you
there's people in the chat right now
that would pay a hundred dollars to
watch you do that dance there are people
on the show that would pay
I I I would pay some money if you did a
video like this I'm not gonna lie I'm
not gonna lie I had basement money who
knows you know the people paying me
enough money anyway this is her I think
I think we also need to understand the
psychology of what happened to Britney
Spears during this time now a lot of
people who might be coming kind of new
five thousand dollars all right I can do
that are we doing an auctions
[Music]
so I think a lot of this has to do with
the fact that people might not might not
have seen Brittany lately and the only
reason they're seeing this video is
because of the recent story that came up
over this past week right with the like
oh did she grab or did she get slab or
you know all that stuff to happen in
Vegas
so when I think a lot of people are
seeing here is the first time maybe in a
while they've seen Britney Spears and
they might be like what the [__] going
on this is nothing new she's been doing
this for a while she's been stuck in her
house during the pandemic under
conservatorship doing this exact same
thing there's actually I think it's a
New York Times like mini doc on Hulu
definitely recommended it's the free
Britney movement about her about her
ending of her conservatives yeah it's
leading up to the moments right before
they they finalized uh her being free of
that so I think a lot of this is is her
because we also have to remember what we
did to Britney Spears as
the media and society and everything
because I would look at the situation
that she has right now she's rich but
she's alone she is not able to go
socialize she's unable to go do
everything else you know there was a
whole like
child endangerment then there was the
Shaving of the head then there is
constant stress from paparazzis and the
media to constantly come at at our
celebrities and add our personalities to
say like when are they going to fail
when are they going to fail when are
they going to fail and you as that
person that personality having that
constant stress on you is emotionally
and mentally taxing that
I'm not surprised that a lot of people
in those positions do the things they do
you know I'm glad you brought that up
and because
um I've watched a couple videos and I
don't know if it was on YouTube or where
but they were shorts it's about Justin
Bieber because Justin Bieber has been
under the same scrutiny where they
follow him around and they just they're
up your ass on every part of your life
right and everything you do is
scrutinize they're there as soon as you
fail right right they'll push you to
that point right so there's videos of
Justin Bieber like when he's going to
his car and these people are like
yelling he's like look guys I know you
got a job to do I know you got to take
pictures of me and I want you to get
your shots of me because that's your job
because I can't I can't stop you from
getting the shots but don't yell at me
like don't yell at me and ask me
questions I'm not here to do an
interview I'm here to live my life and
you're here to [__] get your pictures
of me living my life so let's just do
that if they were up to me I would make
this illegal because I have seen so many
living in Hollywood living in La like
I've seen so many times times where
there have been accidents that have been
caused by Paparazzi and if you were to
ever encroach on their physical you know
area or touch them in some manner they
will immediately sue you for
um well don't you think that's part of
the
gigaby I mean I I think it's in the same
way that there are those scummy lawyers
who are ambulance Chasers I look at
Paparazzi the same way
they will invade your privacy they will
you know the Daily Mail there's a
lawsuit in terms of hacking Prince
Harry's uh I think it was phone or
computer
they got access to certain details that
no one would be privy to the paparazzi
will go above and beyond to get that one
photo right there was even a there was
even a video or there was an episode of
the most recent Black Mirror season
season six where there's a whole episode
about Paparazzi and and and it kind of
takes a turn that you don't really
expect but it's one of those things
where you look at this and I look at the
paparazzi industry as
uh it is a poison
so many people have to live under this
constant stress and fear if I don't go
out a certain way or look a certain way
they're going to get that moment and say
oh my God this person is [__] cracked
out because they God forbid they walk
down sweatpants and woke up right but
it's but it's us that judges them the
paparazzi just takes the pictures it's
that's the is Judgment yeah I mean
they're feeding that and that's what
right that's what they've taught us I
mean this is this is a behavior that
we've been taught and they and it's a
cycle that continues to run through and
so when I look at stuff like this right
the Judgment that happens it's like well
you might think that this is unusual but
this also might be the product of years
and years and years and years and years
of trauma and stress that are put on
someone but read or tweet here here's
the tweet that she sent with this video
right let me let me say that's a
slightly different take okay well let me
let me read the tweet that she sent with
this she says great news coming tomorrow
and she says don't say anything I'm so
so excited I can't wait to share the
news with y'all and she's dancing
happily like she would in any music
video
any music video I don't understand what
the problem with this is now here here
was my my response to it
um I said I can't stop watching this you
do you Brit you just do you just do you
this is this is fantastic I am so happy
that she's happy right because and and
and we should have happiness that she's
happy not not sad we shouldn't be sad
that she's showing her happiness here
now she might be under the influence but
hell when am I not under the influence
half the time
I mean no I'm getting stoned and drunk
all the time what the hell's the
difference yeah and quickly before text
ball goes the reason that or people are
asking like should go on a tour again
it's because she's releasing her Memoir
right right or like the or the Britney
because she finally has the ability she
finally has the ability to do it right
so I'm sure we're gonna hear a lot of
crazy [__] in there the tea will be
spilled and people will probably have a
new understanding of Britney's situation
because I think it's really [__] up I
just based on what we've seen and what
we haven't seen you know and Paul you
sent me the link to the guardian article
where they're they're talking about that
but go ahead and give us your your take
on it while I'm pulling that up well you
know I I agree 100 with what Gabe's
saying about you know a lot of this what
seems normal about this to Brittany is
because she has been sexualized her
entire life right folks she was 16 years
old when we started all watching her
videos and every middle-aged white guy
out there you know I remember guys I was
young in the 90s I mean I was not as old
as I am now down
is so freaking creep wait a second we
try to stick to the facts here Texas
Bowl
he says I was a young guy in the 1990s
Texas ball I was a young guy in the
1990s okay but I was I was I I am I am a
product and Gabe Sanchez is too we are
the product Britney Spears first came
out I was not yet 30 years old that's
how long ago this was I was not yet 30
years old and what what what Gabe is
saying about how
15 16 17 18 years old she was a
completely sexualized by men everywhere
and not only not only that she the
biggest star on Earth because of it she
was the biggest star on Earth because I
I was I was in I was in Middle School
right I was in Middle School when
Britney Spears came on the scene and I
mean I was a because she how old is she
how old is Brittany she's 41. so that's
where I was going with her so she's
three years older than me okay so when
she came on the scene I was 13 years old
like I just found my you know you know
what I'm saying I just found the ability
that you can do things what what
I thought I thought we were in a safe
space here I thought I could talk about
how you know young boys find their Putt
and they play with it Jesus Christ
what's wrong with you dude yeah
don't act like talking about when he was
an adolescent not today yeah hey hey
look I I've never put the thing down
once I found it okay it's just the thing
that I've done I'm not gonna lie to you
I'm not gonna act like that I I don't I
don't do that come on come on you you
you can act like it but I'm not gonna
act like I forget but Britney Spears
Britney Spears Christina Aguilera
um were the two that competed for uh
young adolescence boys PUD time and then
I mean they also they also pitted them
against each other too well absolutely
and that was the other problem that's
the other reason why people look at
Brittany and Christina and they're like
they're [__] nuts well yeah they're
yeah they're a little they're not normal
average people they were they were young
young children when this stuff was
happening to them they never got a
chance to be a normal average teenager
or normal average
had a wealthy guy walk up to her when
she was not yet old enough to take a
drink of alcohol and offer to buy her an
island for doing vile things I guarantee
you that happened
um that I'd had the normal upbringing I
want to bring something up Brendan Lewis
says here put it down or you'll go blind
I got perfect vision 20 20 baby okay so
that's all aligned then your your
parents telling you that [__] uh you're
wrong
listen if we're if we're going to be
honest here which we should be about
Britney Spears because
um again this is about
oh is that the reason why you have
glasses Texas Paul
um Britney Spears is doing this uh uh
they call it Brave on uh Guardian which
I'm sure it is great to tell part of her
story I'm sure there's [__] that she
wouldn't want to write about herself or
anyone knowing
um that we don't already know because we
know some wild [__] about Britney Spears
so there's no telling uh what is gonna
well no I mean I think the I think the
the other part of it too is we only know
one side right right we only know the
side that the media has portrayed which
was oh my God Britney Spears went into
that barber shop and cut her hair off
right we don't know what because we
we've never been able to see her side
we've never been she's never been never
been able to tell her story like any
educated guess we can assume what led
her to do that right we don't we don't
know the extremes of that and the
specifics of it we can have a bit of an
understanding but I'm sure in this book
it's going to break down be like I'm
sure that phase in the early 2000s is
going to be a significant part because
that's where if you were to consider
like somebody having a path of like all
right you know somewhat normal
successful like healthy life let's say
where everything appears normal versus
everything goes into a downward spiral
and everyone is in the media is feeding
into it to know oh crazy or wacko
Brittany you know
um I'm sure that's going to be one of
those like this is the the defining
moment on on how someone's life changes
and I think for her though who knows I
mean there's probably other stuff in
there you know when when she married
Kevin they had their kids they've got to
separate their conservatorship all of
this stuff is going to play into it her
relationship with her sister right
everything that happens and the way that
her family either abandoned her or took
advantage of her or all of those things
that we've heard whispers about
well I I'm sure she's gonna drop this
bombshell and everyone's been like oh
[__] like we had an idea but we never
knew it to this extent
can I can I finish up yeah exactly what
he's saying right there
what I started with was talking about
yeah the sexualization of this this
woman when she was a child she is not a
child she is 41 years old there's
nothing insane about what she's doing in
that video other than the fact that it
looks like she had a big breakfast
before she did it whenever whenever they
go on stage they go on a liquid diet
they you know they will have a they will
do sit-ups they will have a flat stomach
sorry I'm moving so much I'm making my
Camera blur
um but folks
you sexualized her
when she was a child you were the one
licking your damn screens and and and
you sexualized her You by her pointing
at me I feel like you go out and buy her
damn book she's 41 years old now
she is working she is you know I've seen
a bit of a relationship with her
children she's working on that you did
this to her you did
grown-ups take your ass out and buy her
damn book
I bet it's gonna be a good [__] book
to you I bet because Britney Spears is
rich as [__] I mean she's got a boatload
of money and I bet that she was able to
hire a really good Ghost Rider I want to
get to some comments here real quick
um apparently I think her dad screwed up
our estate quite a bit actually well if
she you could screw it up and she's
still worth gazillions of dollars she
ain't gonna run out of money
um a big staff fan on Twitch says zero
days on the porn counter yes uh that is
true
um some Rhonda on Facebook says TMI Tony
uh political T says you're 38 yes I'm
38. I I said that
um someone says I'm getting gross but we
do have some people wanting a spin-off
here porn cast uh Tony porncast the Tony
Michaels porn guest I don't know maybe
maybe we can make it a thing I don't
know I'm just I just want to get to a
few comments there I will not be making
guest appearances on
hey well um apparently it's too much
information that I go solo so you know
it happens but I want to finish with
this with no pun intended with uh
with um the Britney Spears story listen
I saw this video this morning and I see
a lot of people
he mute you muted
you muted your mic we can't hear you
you're talking yourself
nope can't hear you what about now now
we can yeah okay yeah I can't hear you
guys yeah we don't know what you were
saying maybe it is who knows hang on let
me go out and come back I think Karma
was protecting you my friend I
can't hear [__] yeah I can't hear [__]
hang on let me let me go out I'll come
back game let's run with this give me a
few seconds give me a few seconds
to finish up and then then I'll come
back and I'll um
I agree with 100 of what you were saying
about her sexualization and why she went
through the troubles that she went
through that is on us that is on yeah I
mean I could not imagine
I was such a dumbass at 16 17 18 years
old
the advice that she got they rode her
like a pony and put her away soaking wet
they did I mean we have to remember that
you know one I can't remember it was the
first music video it might have been you
know Hit Me Baby One More Time right and
then we had 99 yeah where she was
dressed up as a school girl that's a
fetish she's dancing crop top tied shirt
ponytails it's a complete sexualization
of a of a huge song child and put her in
that place and at that moment she was
introduced and that's what she and I'm
sure at the time she's like oh this is
fun this is great right and making these
music videos are so great
but at a certain point you have to and
you look all the way back you know
whether it's Justin Bieber or other
young art Selena Gomez all these other
younger artists we do the same thing
it's not just the people of that same
age demographic that are watching but
older people as well whether they're
creepy or whatever it might be but it
the society
was scaring me in the chat he is
literally scaring me
Edward
what is that I don't know who's Edward
what is his name
oh
Edward Anderson
Edward what are you doing I'm trying to
look for a chat right now
he says oh come on Paul you can be on
the porn cast and your shiny Cayman
boots and assless chaps boy
nobody wants to see this naked and I
ain't embarrassing myself like that
my wife doesn't want to see me naked
okay yeah I don't want to see myself
naked you know I got my own stuff oh
Tony says he has to restart the whole
[__] I don't know what's going on he has
to restart his computer but anyway I
will say this I wouldn't be surprised if
the book that she releases you know
because also like I'm glad that she's
able to tell her story right because
again we've only had it one we've only
had it one side of this whole time we
only know what the media portrayed we
don't know what it's been like inside of
those situations inside of the limo
inside of the car inside of whatever it
might be and so I look at this
opportunity for her to release this book
and I wouldn't be surprised if this
becomes a huge huge best seller because
her music spans several like it's your
generation My Generation you know people
who are discovering gen Z in terms of
like what she's gone through and people
who are fighting for her rights to be
released from her uh you know
conservatorship under her father and
what her father did
um so I look at this and I say like this
is a huge opportunity also to talk about
what that's like right not only the
pressure of the media and others
expectations from society and and uh you
know also fearing the position that
people put you in and whether you should
become that thing right if if someone's
like oh you're you're terrible and
you're evil and then someone's like well
I might as well be the villain or if
they're like oh you're you know I'm
gonna sexualize you or sledgeham you or
whatever it might be and then you're
like well I might as well be the thing
that everyone thinks I'm gonna be and
it's unfortunate and sad that we as a
society have to go to that but I I look
at this book and I see it as a huge
Silver Lining to to call that [__] out
right I wouldn't be surprised if she
starts dragging people through the mud
and says look there's this person that
was [__] creepy and there was this
exec and there was this label and there
was this thing and I remember this time
when I was this age and they tried to do
this and she starts calling all these
people out and I'm I I look at this and
I'm like I'm happy and it's like no
wonder she's dancing right she's excited
that the thing that she wrote is able to
uh get the light shine on it that it
should be right yeah and not only was it
half the story I mean you know as you're
talking about her kids were drugged
through this I mean you didn't see much
of our of our kids being put out in the
public but they had to go to school
folks that that is a huge thing that she
is working on with her children today is
she has been a spectacle her entire life
and her father I I I have I don't know I
I don't know what's happened inside that
relationship but I do not
my red flags are up
the [__] that got released about her did
not come off to me as somebody
protecting his daughter they came off to
me as somebody trying to remain in
control
and I just uh you know I I just think
there's going to be a lot there and I
folks I really I'm telling you I'm
telling you this is going to be a good
book this is going to be a good book it
took me a second sorry I had to take a
few minutes to uh
reset the computer reset yeah reset if
that's what you wanna if that's you I
just sent you the link you know if you
wanna we can wrap this up on this one
but yeah if I just sent you a link for
the announcement this is this is the the
book announcement that she did
officially
yeah yeah and think about how brilliant
this is guys people are like oh she's
crazy we need to worry about her there's
that and the other
my Jeep she just she just dropped this
yeah she just Spears just took control
of a news cycle in which a former
president has been indicted is facing
more charges there's news that's going
on there and uh you know she took
control of an entire news cycle right
when she's about to start selling a book
guys this isn't crazy to me this is
freaking brilliant you know I mean it
just is
on a website says the woman in me is a
brave and astonishingly moving story
about Freedom Fame motherhood survival
Faith and Hope so well here's here's the
here's the video she released on her
Twitter uh account just not but 2015 20
minutes ago
it does does it have some sound I don't
know I don't think it has no it's just
the book there it is yeah on the on the
website it says in June 2021 the world
was listening to Britney as as Britney
Spears spoke in court the impact of
sharing her voice or truth was
undeniable and it changed the course of
her life and the lives of countless
others the woman in me reveals for the
first time her incredible journey and
the strength at the core of one of the
greatest performers in pop music history
written with remarkable Candor and humor
Spears is groundbreaking book
illuminates the enduring power of music
and love and the importance of a woman
telling her own story on her own terms
at last
well I'm glad that Britney's doing her
and I'm glad that she gets to finally
tell her story the way that she uh She's
Fit to tell her story I think that's
important
um for every woman out there I'll give
you one small glimpse a little inside
baseball you know the hair shaving yeah
it went on the the background story
behind that is Kevin Federline who took
a complete pass on all this for being a
complete jackass dick of a father turned
around called her and told her I'm
taking the kids there's not a goddamn
thing you can do about it I know you did
drugs and they can drug test your hair
follicles and I can prove it I'm taking
you to court immediately so what did she
do like a dumb ass didn't understand
what a hair follicle was went into the
first Barber Shop she could find and
very publicly said [__] you Kevin
and shaved her head off shaved her hair
off that was the story behind you're
going to hear a lot more stories like
that you know Kevin Federline took a
huge pass because she didn't come out
punching on at Kevin Federline like
Kevin Federline did her
you know she didn't wasn't in a
situation where her dad was trying to
take control of her damn estate and was
shooting her in the ad you're going to
hear a lot of good stories in this book
yeah I promise I'm I'm excited for her
to write a book I'm excited for her to
finally tell her side of the story
um you know and and because it is her
story and no one else's and they've
worked so long to keep her side of the
story out of the Limelight let's go to a
different story though
um this doesn't have to do with
um pop icons this has to do with just
[__] eaters uh the Republicans
um
Republicans love their criminals here's
here's Benji Johnson oh Benji simping
for for Trump
simping over Donald Trump which I think
is the one thing I will say that beach
photo of or that video of Joe Biden yeah
everyone's like oh man look at this guy
he's senile decrepit and frail and he's
weak and he's pale and all stuff and I'm
like do you guys even look I'm not here
to body shame but like if we're gonna
compare two different people and the one
person that you guys are shooting up
there is a candidate for 2024
have you seen that man and have you seen
him without a shirt on at a beach well
the other thing too is they're like
the other thing too they're like oh
anyone over 80 I'm like
um dude uh do you know the guy down at
Mar-A-Lago how old he is like come on
man get the [__] out of here with this
nonsense but here is here's 79 is so
much younger than me right right exactly
I mean I mean it's like light years away
right okay so here's Benji Johnson
simping for Donald Trump uh showing Ron
Johnson simping for Donald Trump and
this fake whistleblower well we we heard
this news
from James Comer and Jim Jordan that
they had this whistleblower that's going
to blow the socks off [__] and since
last year since last year you know James
Comer said I am going to hold President
Biden accountable he made those promises
right before
they took over the majority right
exactly majority right
so they had this whistleblower and like
no this guy this guy's got the skinny on
Hunter and Joe okay he's got skinny on
him but we can't find him for some
reason they lost him Texas Paul
well it seems like it seems like
he's not a whistleblower he's a he's a
Chinese spy
oh the fact bat she's a Chinese isn't he
also an Iranian spy as well he's an
Iranian spy he's also he's also um an
illegal
uh um what that what they charge him
with the the weapons not weapons charged
the Arms Dealer arms dealer yeah there
you go add the movie with uh Jonah Hill
always comes to mind and then the one
with Nick Cage
um
Lord of War Lord of War and then the
other one was that's a good one yeah War
Dogs yeah war dogs with Jonah Hill and
um uh what's his name anyway yeah that's
it that's it but here Jonah Hill's
another one that's in a [__] oh man I I
I'd love to have time for that scumbag
yeah sometimes you just you look at
these people you're like oh [__] I used
to like you you know what I mean it's
good let's go along today Tony let's do
it
but here's here's Ron Johnson
um when he but here's the thing it's
Benny Johnson defending this [__] he
says Senator Ron Johnson demands
that anti-biden whistleblower dude you
can't say the quiet part out loud any
more than that can you anti-biden
whistleblower to be granted immunity to
testify against Biden crime family after
being indicted by doj okay so this guy
is being indicted by the doj because
he's a Chinese spy you think the
Republican party Black China China China
China China you're getting money from
China oh if you get money from China
you're the best worst China China in the
China China oh my God
and and they just ignore they ignore the
fact that the doj's like ah this guy's a
Chinese spy wouldn't it but here's Ron
Johnson let's listen to Putin's puppets
see what he has to say about the Chinese
spy when he heard that Joe Biden was
gonna be running for president that
alarmed him because he knew how
compromised Joe Biden would be so he met
with two prosecutors from the southern
district of New York and four FBI agents
in Brussels for two days in March of
2019. okay what Ron Johnson is failing
to tell the audience is that he was paid
to do all this [__] okay when you're a
shiny spy and you're an illegal arms
dealer you will deal in any [__]
thing someone will pay you money to do
you dumb [__] Ron Johnson what
don't you understand about this you
[__] fool they paid him to go say
this to people they paid him to go say
this to people wait wait wait wait wait
wait oh yeah are you telling me yeah
at the Republican party yeah they got a
whistleblower who made it claim yeah Joe
Biden was involved in some bribery
scheme yeah
100 million 200 million 300 million but
it turns it's worse but it but it but
you're telling me that they made these
claims and then it turns out that they
that this guy this whistleblower was
getting money to say these things uh
well I mean it's even worse go ahead and
worse go ahead and tell us this guy we
know what he's testifying to he's not
testifying to first-hand knowledge he's
not
he's testifying that he talked to a guy
that is as shitty and shady as they get
in China and this guy told him this it's
not even firsthand testimony but worse
even worse this guy knew he was going to
be indicted he knew his I mean
I mean it was over he made a deal with
Republicans for protection
from indictments if he would come spill
[__] it's not just he got paid
he is getting literally the Republicans
are literally protecting a criminal who
knew he was about to be indicted
so that he will just say bad [__] about
the bidens well they are selling out
that bad here's the thing too and I want
to give all people out there who support
Republican causes and continue the grift
and continue the lies let me tell you
something I I want to be upfront with
you about this and I want to tell you
this for sure
Congress people senators
do not have a way to protect you okay
that's not a thing it's not their job to
protect you from prosecution now they
can make suggestions they know the right
people they know the contacts but
Senator Ron Johnson can't Grant this guy
immunity okay he can't do it he can go
on Fox News and pretend like you can he
can go on Fox News and call it like he
thinks he can but he can't Jim Comer
can't protect you Jim Jordan can't
protect you Matt gatz can't protect you
there was a story here recently that
[__] scumbag Tara Reid who who
falsely accused Joe Biden of [__]
defected to Russia because Matt gatz
told her he couldn't protect her you
dumb [__] Congress people can't
protect you from prosecution they're not
part of that part of government they're
not you stupid bastards know how our
government is structured this is the
dumbest [__] I ever heard of let's
continue to see what Senator dunbuck has
to say about immunity he's going to say
something stupid I just know it he's Ron
Johnson I just know it what's
interesting about those individuals one
of the prosecutors from the southern
district of New York is the same
prosecutor the prosecuted Patrick ho the
the money launderer that paid 100 buying
a million dollars to defend him and in
that trial he prevented the name of
bidens from being brought into court
also one of the FBI agents was the same
agent then that signed the subpoena from
the hunter Biden laptop Hey Ron Hey Ron
I get that you're trying to spread your
lies but how about you bring the same
energy for individual one you
[__] how about that how about
you bring the same energy for individual
one in the Roger Stone prosecution you
piece of [__] trash this happens all
the time you dumb [__] it
happens all the time individual one is
just one instance of this where they
leave politicians names because they're
not a Target in the investigation at the
time they leave their [__] names off
the map it happens all the time Ron
Johnson let's continue with his
stupidity so you know what what uh Mr Dr
lot is showing is the same Financial
transactions the millions of dollars the
hundred thousand dollar per month
retainer for Hunter sixty five thousand
dollars for James Biden paid by cefc
he's got a wealth of information but
they never followed up on that meeting
instead they arrested him in Cyprus
to silence him they could have gone to
Israel he resides in Israel we have
extradition treaties but they instead
arrest him in Cyprus now he's literally
fleeing for his life right now he's he's
on the Run oh my God oh my God oh my God
why do you think he's on the run right
maybe he's [__] a criminal hey what
do you think he was arrested in Cyprus
Texas Paul let me tell you something
because I want you to speak on this
because I think I think you could
probably do this well there's a reason
why this is all so complicated right
this story of this crime is so
complicated and this story of why he's
innocent and why it's all the Deep State
the reason why it's so complicated can
you tell the audience why the
Republicans have to have these stories
to be so complicated they have to have
all these integral parts that make no
sense that really have nothing to do
with each other it's just oh 100 Biden
here and Hunter Biden there see these
two things are exactly the same why does
it have to be so complicated why
because their voters are stupid because
their voters have no clue when he like
he just threw Patrick ho out there right
patricko was a Hong Kong businessman
that used an American Bank to transfer
bribes to Africa okay not even here
he hired Hunter Biden
as a consultant
because he was about to go through some
things here he doesn't live here he
doesn't understand our system
Hunter Biden sat him down and said look
you committed serious crimes in the
United States of America when you use
your American bank account to transfer
bribes they have your ass
his defense immediately changed to I'm
guilty Let's Make a Deal
I mean he didn't I mean it was really
he did right by his his customer
and he throws it out there like Hunter
Biden did something nefarious there he
defended he was paid a million dollars
by Patrick who yeah because he was his
Warrior he was his lawyer yeah
and and they he just throws it out there
like it somehow
nefarious and oh that that makes gal
Luft seem more credible no gal Luft is a
freaking spy he did not tell the
American government that he was a spy
he's a spy for China he's a spy for Iran
he's a freaking arms dealer that lies
about being an arms dealer and they've
got him nailed to the wall and he went
to Republicans to have his ass protected
he made a deal I will say [__] about
Hunter Biden for you because y'all
believe Hunter Biden's Gonna Save You
right 2024. I'll say [__] that your
stupid voters won't understand because I
seem like fancy you know I mean they
don't know who I am I'm an Israeli I I
run a think tank and I'm you know I mean
[__] the guy was a freaking criminal
he was arrested in freaking Cyprus
because he was trying to move money out
of a cypriot bank accounts and they
snagged him before he could do what he
did you need to do to go on the Run
also climbing is priming is funny isn't
it quick uh quick back check on that
Johnson claim in terms of why they
arrested him in Cyprus versus Israel and
he goes why didn't they do in Israel
they have extradition
they don't do that they don't extradite
their own Nationals okay anyone who is
there he is a dual citizen U.S Israel
which you can't have citizenship in yes
so they they would not be able to
actually based on what I've just quickly
looked through his background and also
what extradition laws are between the
U.S and Israel their rule their law is
that we cannot extradite any Israeli
National citizen
if a crime was committed while they were
in Israeli National citizen and he's had
it for any number of years and these
crimes happen within the last handful
years so the claim that Johnson goes
well they could have extradite from
Israel no we couldn't have there's a
problem there's most likely a reason
why they did it in Cyprus because
they're like we can get him here once he
goes in Israel it's going to be a
[__] [__] show
he was a lieutenant colonel
in the Israeli military he served in the
intelligence branch of the Israeli
military he was a lieutenant they do not
extradite their officers from their
military for any reason anywhere
that's part of the deal Israel does [__]
that most militaries won't do they kill
people on foreign soil they do that's
why everybody always looks at at Israel
as they're such bad asses because they
will go murder people in the middle of
Europe but the deal is you make it home
you're safe we will not extradite you
for any reason and Johnson knows this he
is flat out like you said Tony the
reason why his voters are freaking
morons exactly what's your point is so
complicated you will say they could have
arrested him in Israel [__]
they arrested him in Cyprus because he
was grabbing his money and running
cypriot Banks Cyprus if people don't
know has become the hub for the Middle
East it is the banking hub for the
Middle East and they are cleaning their
act up because there's more money to be
made in the legitimate world than the
freaking criminal world and that's why
gal love got arrested in Cyprus because
the bank that he does business with said
hello America
God left is moving lots of money you
should come here
okay so here's the thing too
on the whole complicated thing the
reason why they make it complicated is
so dummy sounds smart that's what to
make it simple so dummies sound smart
because what happens is these [__]
idiots will go online and they'll type
this [__] out and like see I'm so smart
because I know all these connections
because Ron Johnson told me and it
sounds really complicated no you're a
[__] idiot you're a [__] idiot
none of that [__] matters none of that
[__] matters to the story of why this
guy is indicted and none of it matters
of why Republicans saw an opportunity
for this guy to say [__] so they could
get a story and get it out there that
the narrative that somehow Hunter Bond
and Joe Biden or the two evil demons
controlling the world and they're gonna
destroy it single-handedly even though
Joe Biden is some kind of decrepit old
man with Dimension can't can't get his
shoes or socks on and Hunter Biden's a
[__] crackhead who loves prostitutes
but they're going to control the world
and they're gonna destroy it all okay
what it really is do you want to know
what it really is it's a [__] grift
there's a Gibson go so to stand with
this guy okay here's the campaign
they're using the [__] video I just
showed you that Benji's like yeah this
is awesome they're using the [__]
video I just showed you now this is why
I bring this up is because this makes
dummies feel smart and when dummies feel
smart their wallets get [__] loose
for you and this is what this is this is
money laundering 101. they're gonna dump
a ton of money into defending this guy
because this guy knows the truth about
Hunter Biden and they're gonna launder
the [__] money you [__] fools out
there giving money to this idiot now um
this is brought up by our friend who
follows gives gives and go like a
[__] we've actually had him on
the show was it good Gibson go with the
the trucker Convoy thing yep yep uh
Hi-Fi
um it brings us up he says I'm once
again again asking anyone in position of
authority to investigate Gibson go for
money laundering I think it's a little
more complicated and I think the
Canadian government actually did a
little bit of investigating into Gibson
go after the Convoy thing but this just
shows you this just shows you why they
try to make the dumb look smart it's
it's that's all that's the tactic that's
the tactic is make all these things up
say all these complicated things and all
these complicated connections so the
dumb look smart that's all it is that's
all it is so that way you'll [__] get
loose with your wallet why do you think
Trump talks about the presidential
records act the case that is against him
has nothing not a goddamn thing not one
[__] thing about that case in South
Florida has anything to do with the
presidential records act none of it none
of it because the presidential records
act doesn't allow him to have these
records at mar-lago you [__]
okay they're trying to make something
complicated they're trying to make the
dumb look smart while saying
presidential records acting the
president gets the right to do anything
he wants and he can do this and he can
magically they gotta [__] make it all
complicated so the dumb look smart
that's what it is so they can grift off
of them I'd like to throw a PSA out
there to anybody thinking about working
uh thinking about working with
Republicans let me use gal Luft as an
example
gal Luft has no
testimony that is worth a [__] in a
hearing he will be utterly destroyed in
a hearing because it will be did you
actually hear Hunter Biden say that well
no my friend Bing Ho Wah told me what
what what what you you don't have actual
testimony and you're you're quoting a
Chinese criminal that's also a Chinese
spy the one that they use against the
one that they use against Center Biden
yeah he has no value as a witness
but they're going to make a ton of money
off of him as a martyr they are because
he will never see a hearing he will
never see a courtroom they will make a
ton of money pretending he has valid
information
and they were like Tony's just said I
mean just showed you it's a grift it's
it's all a grip if you're thinking about
cooperating with the Republican party
please no they are not going to help you
but they are going to make a lot of
money off your corpse they are well I
got I got another Ron Johnson Griff
story here to tell you
um you guys you guys heard about the
live golf and PGA combining right the
Saudis buying out PGA it's kind of weird
that a that a for-profit organization is
buying a non-profit organization they're
staying um it's really [__] weird
anyways Ron Johnson uh is asked this
question here about Saudi money and is
it offensive that
um we would let Saudi money buy
something like PJ since it's the Saudis
that flew the planes into the buildings
you guys remember that it was like um as
several years ago is on September I
believe it was the 11th that it happened
but let's see what Ron Johnson has to
say about his Sympathy for the families
of 9 11. you have an issue with Saudi
money being used uh to have either a
partnership or an ownership of the PGA
Tour do you have a problem with that
well sorry the deepest sympathy for the
9 11 families I understand the issue of
sports washing I don't think there's any
bill there's not enough billions of
dollars for the Saudis to wash away the
stain of the brutal khashoggi's murder
um but the reality is you know we all
buy oil we use
but you know I have the deepest
sympathies for khashoggi his family and
the 911 families but [__] it I like
money better I like money better hey if
you don't think that's what he says wait
I'll I'll show you I'll show you that's
exactly what he says all right go ahead
go ahead Putin's puppet you know we
drive cars you know we we are the ones
that are filling up the coffers of the
public investment fund I would rather
have their them you know the Saudis
investor oil wealth in the U.S as
opposed to China or Russia that's just
reality of the world
um and again you know I'm I'm a lover of
the game of golf I love watching golf I
want to see the best golf golfers in the
world compete against each other and not
be split into different leagues and
pretty well destroy the competition at
the highest okay so the idea of
competition would be that there would be
several leagues that would have to
compete with each other I don't know if
he knows how competition Works Texas
Paul does he know that when when one
league has owns all the leagues and all
the tournaments that there is no
competition does he know that I don't
think he knows that
he's such a he knows it but the
dumbasses he's talking to will oh well
that makes sense that that makes a lot
of sense to me I mean you know you're
gonna have more competition when you got
one one operation running everything hey
Ethel hey Ethel did you hear that that
sounds really smart that's what we'll
say when we go down to the to the
Captain D's to get our coupons later on
we'll tell that to George George will
really think we're smart when we say
what Senator [__] just said on Fox
Business what a [__] idiot what a
[__] idiot and there's gonna be
people
puking this [__] up that yeah you know
it's a bad thing that the 911 families
and could show you that's bad you know
that's all bad I I really I have I have
not forgotten I have not forgotten 911
but look when you pile money on top of
it I might forget a little bit I might
forget just a little bit and then you
know you tend you tend to forget things
when uh
what a piece of [__] what a piece of
[__] it's not surprising coming from
[__] Ron Johnson but they're all
pieces of [__] man it's the same reason
though the [__] over the constituents
they won't do anything to support them
they'll do a bunch of fake outrage talk
about woke stoves and this crazy
whistleblower that's on the run but it's
missing but it's not that whistleblower
it's the informant but then you find out
that it's all connected to this and oh
you know what in the people people that
were connected to 911 I mean was really
so bad you know because it's like money
is better so it's like oh there's such
[__] boxes there's such [__] boxes but
they're Republicans like Gabe said and
we'll stay on their ass I have 15 more
stories that we should do today but we
just don't have time we're out of time
we went over anyways make sure to go to
realtexaspaul.com it's down below and in
the link down below
realtexaspaul.com he's going to do a
show tomorrow on Wednesdays before our
show make sure to go realtexaspaul.com
to find that Gabe Sanchez yeah but what
was that coming up I know you kind of I
am wrapping up but what was that on
Margaret Taylor green get her get there
coming out today and then and I gotta
I'm gonna try and whip out another one
whip it out whip it out
send me those man send me those on
threads I'll put whenever you get a walk
with that up send me a link to that so I
can put it out for my people man I love
your welcome heaps the peeps the peeps
so all right go go check out what was
that what was that show.com or you can
go to patreon.com
slash I am Gabe Sanchez when you're on
patreon.com visit my page too the Tony
Michaels we didn't ask me anything
yesterday after the show it lasted like
an hour and a half we were talking for a
long time we're talking for a long time
one thing I want to show did you know
this Gabe you can actually look at
threads on a web browser you can look at
it yeah yes just look at it you can't
interact with it you can't like it you
can't go anywhere you can just look at
it and not have the handle I think to
type in how do you find it on your web
browser though I don't know somebody
have to link it to you or you you just
share it and yeah you just copy the link
as soon as you try to interact then
it'll be like scan the code to download
the yeah well here here I'll show you
I'll show you I'll show you what happens
hey I want to like this one oh go
download the app [__]
yo download that [__] so now I think I
think um some stuff is changing threads
this morning did you see this
um they're putting each individual
person who follows you now you can click
the follow button it's easier to follow
people who follow you I noticed that uh
so there's going to be changes that are
going to happen continually so it's
gonna it's not gonna look the same as it
does now two weeks from now a month from
now two months from now it's gonna look
completely different I mean it's gonna
look the same but it's gonna have a lot
of different functionality my guess is
they're gonna have the desktop version
ready as soon as they can
um you think it'll be before they let a
stream to it Tony well I mean they're
gonna have to have some sort of
um they're gonna have to have some sort
of platform in there to let us well I
mean they already have it built in with
Instagram so I wouldn't be surprised I
mean I have it built in with Facebook
and Instagram so they're probably just
going to build on top of the existing
technology right
that they built not Elon Musk uh and
they're going to allow streaming to
happen so I I would imagine I don't know
I mean like they've they've got a lot of
features they want to do I I know that
so I wouldn't be surprised if in the
next few months you know maybe six
months as long as but I would I could
see them doing it quickly because
they're trying to compete against I will
tell you when we can stream two threads
I will not stream on Twitter anymore I'm
not because there's no use in it because
Periscope is garbage absolutely [__]
garbage
um but but threads is there go follow go
follow Texas Paul go follow Gabe on
threads follow me on threads and and you
can you can find this pretty easy just
type in our handles but again I think
Texas Paul you have yours on your
website I'm sure go to realtexaspaul.com
uh you can go to Gabe's linktree you can
go to my link tree and go to the Tony
michaels.com you can find it all there
make sure to make sure to subscribe here
at the Tony Michaels podcast you're not
going to want to miss a single episode
of this show two hours every single
weekday we don't just do politics we do
Britney Spears too here [__] uh get it
straight and if you uh speaking of
Facebook if you want to watch it on
Facebook it's free to watch it over
there at the Tony Michaels on Facebook
you can also follow us for free on
Twitch go to twitch.tv Tony Michaels if
you haven't resubbed resub for us over
there with your Prime account make sure
you're doing that every single month we
appreciate that we just had Bike Shop
Guru just about an hour ago uh
re-subscribe for the fourth month in a
row she gotta do it every single month
so make sure if you're got your Prime
account linked to your Twitch account
you're renewing that uh ever and
re-subbing every single month download
every single episode of the Tony
Michaels podcast on Apple Spotify and
Google
baby uh someone's asking about the small
Rats song I did an Easter egg I've been
doing Easter eggs I did it as an Easter
egg yesterday at the end of the show
um so so small rats thanks for the song
unless he did a new one I don't know if
he did a new one today or not Texas Paul
Gabe's in is I'm glad you guys uh bared
with me with my technical PUD problems
that I had then I had to go um finish
some stuff before I came back on the air
so I'm glad you stuck with me through
that problem everyone same time same
place tomorrow
sir [__] you've been listening
to the Tony Michaels podcast in your
face commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon